[Music]  Katie Couric launching a new show yep  thanks Andy  [Laughter]  she's launching her new daytime show  next week yeah yeah and to build  excitement producers have been releasing  a series of get to know Cady videos and  we showed one last night here's another  one I found a lot my apartment has  gotten a little long in the tooth I mean  it's been this way for almost 15 years  so it probably could use a little a  little pick-me-up one of the most  sentimental things I have in my  apartment is this collection of pill  boxes  I love photographs and my girls used to  be afraid of him but in a way I kind of  felt like he was kind of guarding us  he's staying  [Music]  all right right getting that we're  really getting good now er en I don't  know if that's such a good idea